pas bonjour à tous on a beaucoup parlé
des smartphones avec des écrans pliables
vous en ai parlé en long en large et en
travers ressemble intéresse énormément
on a beaucoup parlé du samsung galaxy x
qu'on a aussi dit qu'apple pourrait se
positionner
on a aussi parlé de huawei justement
aujourd'hui on va parler de huawei
huawei qui pourrait être le premier à
dégainer et à commercialiser son
smartphone avec un écran pliable et sans
en parler
alors les écrans pliables les
smartphones et les écrans pliables ça va
être la grande révolution
on a eu les écrans infiniti les écrans
bord à bord les écrans si les écrans ça
là on va voir des produits tout nouveau
tout beau tout neuf pour les 10 ans du
smartphone 10 11 ans du smartphone des
smartphones avec des écrans pliables
alors me direz vous quel est l'intérêt
ils intéressent elles gagnent place et
c'est le fait d'augmenter la taille de
l'écran pour profiter de différentes
applications ça va être le smartphone du
futur et vous allez voir il va arriver
alors justement on a beaucoup parlé de
samsung et son galaxy x on en parle 2011
pas moi mais beaucoup de monde en parle
depuis 2011 parce que samsung a dit dès
2011 qui travaillait sur un prototype
avec un smartphone avec un écran pliable
ça continue et dans les années on a
parlé la rumeur c'est s'est enflammée
enflammé il y en a de plus en plus et on
n'a jamais vu arriver ce produit sauf
que là ça se précise réellement le
produit de samsung aurait pu arriver en
2018 travailler plus d'arrache-pied il
devrait le sortir début 2019
et justement huawei qui donnait pour
mission de détrôner apple et samsung
dans le domaine des smartphones a dit
nous on va sortir le nôtre avant les
autres alors c'est une info qui nous
vient du médias sud coréens eux des news
qui a effectivement dit que huawei va
sortir son produit fin 2018 en octobre
dernier au web est déjà à dix au site
cnet.com qu'il avait un proto
fonctionnel avec un écran pliable là
effectivement le proto a pris vraiment
en forme il devrait peut être commencer
à fabriquer très très très prochainement
pour être commercialisée fin 2018 il ya
un brevet a été déposé auprès
l'organisation mondiale de la propriété
intellectuelle le 29 mars 2018 qui nous
en dit plus sur ce smartphone ce à quoi
il pourrait ressembler on voit un écran
pliable comme un livre au dos une
charnière en repli comme un bouquin est
un petit charniére au dos et on aura un
écran flexible fabriqué par lg
lg c'est le grand concurrent de samsung
au niveau de la fabrication d'écrans
fabrication oled donc là ça va être une
vraie guerre de tranchées entre les deux
pour fournir l'ensemble du marché
alors du coup ça me sauve lui qui se bat
depuis des années là dessus pourrait se
faire doubler sur la ligne d'arrivée
alors il faut tout mesurer parce que
pour l'instant on est vraiment sur des
produits qui sont tout neufs c'est pas
comme un nouveau smartphone autres
enfin ils se disent des choses comme ça
et les nouveaux iphone disent qu'ils
vont arriver à la fin de l'année là on
est vraiment quelque chose de
complètement nouveau est ce que le
consommateur on va être prêt est ce que
vous vous allez tri est ce que moi je
vais de prêts à l'y dessus en tout cas
ça me plaît bien mais il faut voir une
fois que le produit sera disponible
est ce qu'il va être commercialisé en
toute petite unité c'est ce que
d'ailleurs laisse croire les rumeurs par
rapport à aux projets de samsung qui
pourraient être commercialisés entre 500
et 1000 exemplaires à 2 millions
d'exemplaires pour tester un peu le
marché probablement en corée du sud et
en asie dans un premier temps à voir si
huawei fait exactement la même chose ou
si au contraire ils disent non nous on
va inonder le marché
on va y aller on va faire ou online dès
le début ou alors est-ce qu'ils vont
plutôt égalé en catimini pour essayer
alors dites vous bien que si huawei sort
effectivement sont produits cette fin
d'année et que samsung sort le sien
début 2019
vous allez avoir quoi un mois deux mois
d'intervalle entre les deux ça va être
jouée dans un mouchoir de poche tout le
monde a passé mais sur un produit
directement donc je suis pas sûr que ça
fasse tout de suite de l'ombre à samsung
parce qu'en plus de ça il ya une autre
question qui est très importante est
très intéressante parce que ce que nous
présente ce brevet c'est effectivement
un espèce d'écran pliable qui se servent
comme un bouquin on s'attend à avoir un
écran aussi à l'extérieur pour avoir les
notifications les informations les
messages et des choses comme ça à voir
maintenant comment sera fabriqué le
produit de samsung est ce qu'il sera
plus intéressant ou pas est-ce qu'il
sera plus aboutis ou pas parce que
effectivement huawei pour être le
premier à rentrer dans l'histoire est le
premier à avoir sorti un smartphone avec
un écran pliable
mais lequel aura le vrai succès et le
premier succès commercial s'est pas dit
que ce soit le premier qui dégaine donc
affaire à suivre mais en tout cas chaud
ça vraiment passionnant je sais pas vous
ce que vous en pensez dites-moi est-ce
que vous seriez prêt à aller sur ses
smartphones avec des écrans pliables
est ce que le projet du samsung galaxy x
vous tente
est ce que le huawei avec un écran
pliable mais aussi vous tentez vous
marquez tout sans commentaire on va en
discuter ensemble parce que on a
beaucoup parlé j'ai encore d'autres
choses à vous dire
dans ce domaine là on en est qu'au début
ça va être vraiment passionnante où les
géants commencent à se positionner là
dessus et c'est vraiment un truc de
dingue donc rester connecté mark et moi
vos questions suggestions avis
interrogations tout ça en commentaire
vous avez comme d'habitude à me laisser
des jolies pousse à vous abonner
on reste connectés pour de son goût je
vous embrasse comme d'hab les
aujourd'hui vous fais la bise
vous allez salut à bientôt ciao